[Music]
we've talked about
trump before on this channel
trumpet it takes time or twice man just
a couple times but i don't think we
really covered
biden all that much i don't think we've
covered him once there's an
email yeah it's like you want to choose
uh
one sex offender or another sex offender
thank you you're the sex offender thank
you
yeah like i haven't really hurt like i
try staying away from politics
oh you should see when [ __ ] he
interacts with [ __ ]
that little girl there's a [ __ ] weird
video where he's like
touching he's like caressing her [ __ ]
it's so weird cursing a girl's titties
no
no no i didn't see like no she's like
holding them like this right and then
like the girl's got to be like 13 or
something she
and his hands come out oh that one yeah
and the girl's like all uncomfortable
what's the context of that
uh so they i think it's like a picture
meet and greet type of thing so they're
going to take pictures but he's like
clawing her boobs
then he'll like it's always like like
the appropriate way
for every guy listening out there please
be respectful with especially
you take a picture and you want to be
friendly right
um and you're older or whatever if you
want to take a picture with the
with the girl i mean you can do this but
keep your hand to the side
if you have to however you don't have to
hover it's just like outside of the
shoulder
or it's like like you're not in between
the don't make it awkward
like come here like this is a homie hug
this one because i thought ariana grande
that's how he hugs that's fighting feels
side boob
that's what i do oh i see that's why he
does it people do this because their
hands here and it looks awkward but if
you put your arm and it's like hanging
and that's okay oh true like that's fine
and if you're like
someone but not like but not like but
not like but not like this
exactly so casey can you do it again
yeah any time you hug a female this way
you're gonna make her feel uncomfortable
yeah unwarranted i always grab him
grab females by the way if it's unwanted
why i want it right and i squeeze the
leg like this
yeah or like this oh my god when i sat
on santa and santa's lap once well i was
like 16 me my friend we sat on his lap
and he he placed his hands on her ass
like on this oh you were asking wait how
old were you
16. you're grown you're going through
puberty
he's definitely looking at you in a
different light so he'll do [ __ ] like
that
and then like you'll he doesn't he
doesn't respect
proxemics like in the us we have a
certain like distance
that we are a personal bubble yeah like
our us proximix
yeah and then he'll talk to like kids
and he goes in and you see them kind of
like
like whoa
no way
have i not heard of this he's [ __ ]
weird
and when you see him talking to dudes he
does not do that he does not touch
like dudes that way even him like
holding hillary clinton he's like
she's like you're too old oh my [ __ ] you
later ew
and some people might argue he could be
affectionate but
at a rally he was talking and he was
giving a speech and he was like uh
basically talking about how like uh like
he would be in the pool and all these
kids would come and
they love like like rubbing their hands
up up his legs and like getting up to
like
he said this yeah and then he's like oh
but he was like it's because they like
when my hair like moves in the water
but he's not convicted that's [ __ ]
hilarious
you're sending it this is a lot of weird
[ __ ] there's just a lot of weird
fake fake maybe but no no no it was it
was like he's going
see now like crazy like his all his evil
deeds are just coming out
if you don't vote if you don't vote for
us you ain't black
like come on that is crazy so yeah i
bring up joe biden
because now uh a recent clip of him and
he's like having a a
zoom meeting with i actually didn't
check who these other people oh
this is uh this is a union for hospitals
i recognize that
okay so union for hospital and then
uh because of the context of this clip
i'm just assuming that this is some
form this is this person is like the
representative for the asian community
and then maybe a representative for the
hispanic community i don't know
why just because they're asian or what
does the article say here's what he said
okay
look what he's doing now he's blaming
everything on
trump on on on china he's blaming
everything on the chinese he's blaming
everything
and she looks japanese as [ __ ] as you
well know
when the south korean and and someone oh
she's green too she could be korean they
make no distinction it's asian
what way and he's just using it as a
wedge
so he's accusing of trump being racist
by by being racist by by being raised
exactly
and that's what everyone's on twitter
going on about wait what do you say did
he say
he's close stupid dude don't talk don't
talk
with my south korean and someone from
beijing
they make no distinction it's asian and
that's the way
and he's just using it as a wedge
wait that kind of makes sense i thought
so i guess for the record it's kind of
like
trump has never said those exact words
he just just called it the china virus
literally where it's like
so the way he says it it's like this is
where it originated so if it originated
in mexico i'm calling it the mexican
virus no i know but i'm saying
no but what is saying is he's saying it
like when
trump says china everyone in the world
just thinks asians
and they're blaming all asians and which
is the fair point well that's that's
that's completely fine that i think
which is a fair point because he's
basically calling out trump's racism
right but then a lot of people are also
speculating
biden's own projection of racism and
it's the way that he communicated it
because
this is basically what a lot of people
might hear they go you know how all
those asians look the same anyway
so this is why it's dangerous for trump
to saying that is because
there's no distinction between the races
because what he should have said it
should have been like
when trump uh says it that way it
becomes dangerous ground now because now
it's just fueling
you know racism or whatever but the way
he did it he gave his own examples
that prove that he's being racist like i
can't tell the difference between a
south korean and a beijing
they all look the same to me so that's
what it's that's what it can be taken
and i think that's what some of some
twitter users are taking it as and then
like i i think what makes it feel worse
is the fact that it's almost as if he
was kind of like talking to
this lady here it was like you know you
know people can't tell
the lady's like she's like yup yeah
like i agree so i'm just sure i think
you should give a thumbs down
yeah yeah but it's just like it's one of
those we're like
jeez like these are the two political
candidates we have for president and i'm
like
it sucks either way you're choosing a
poison i heard there's
actually a third option and it's a lady
really it's a
i forgot which maybe some independent
party or the green party well i mean
there usually is other parties on the
ballot yeah okay don't make me pick the
birthday party okay
don't make me do it the birthday party
sounds fun
it's kanye's party yeah you have to well
then you don't have to register never
mind as that
oh really you could vote whatever yeah
oh i see i see yeah is the whole
birthday party thing
happening do you guys know or it was i
think he pulled that i thought
he pulled out but then his crazy [ __ ]
rant video
came out but i think then from there
they're trying to get him into a
hospital oh okay
oh i see i see where the the the rosa
parks didn't free slaves one
that one oh yeah yeah
but yeah so it's kind of like it's it's
interesting to see biden
try to play the race card i feel like
that one was
kind of like i don't know
it could be skewed like both ways but
like it kind of feels just ignorant or
it's like
well as a president you want to you want
to be precise with your wording
so i think that's the issue here is that
he's never obsessed with anything yeah
i mean same with trump it's all [ __ ]
up they're like we have two
idiots i don't know i think i can't
speak english like what the [ __ ]
trump i feel like i don't like trump but
what he's doing he knows what he's
saying he's saying it in those exact
ways
to stir something to [ __ ] you up to make
people mad and
also make his people's true uh thing but
also saving face because
you can't he he didn't say this thing
literally
but you can take it as this way but with
him
he's messing up yeah yeah yeah that's
the difference yeah
this sucks it's [ __ ] hilarious you
know what does suck though
biden's not the people's choice he's the
corporate choice
there's so many people that are who
[ __ ] voted him
like who wanted him true that's true
he's not the people's democratic
candidates at one point that i would
have gladly taken over writing
and yeah is it is it the is it the
boomers and the seniors that
actually voted for fighting because even
if they are
right i don't see them on facebook
proudly talking about it
i don't see any of this [ __ ] because i'm
thinking that if he was the people's
choice
you would see a lot of people backing
them up but it's more it's more like
well i guess
we have to back up our party most people
because i
i try to stay far away from politics
because it's just so exhausting but from
what i have seen
that i've come across a lot of people
were supporting bernie sanders
and uh tulsi and yang yeah tulsi gabriel
i didn't hear that one she was a good
one tulsi i would pick those three over
the two we have right now because yang
was kind of i think he dropped out early
right but it was between tulsi and
bernie tulsi was my
favorite and then i would be like yang
would be second so then
but i think she's a uh she's a she's an
active
she's a military she's senator of hawaii
a senator of hawaii and then she's also
in the military
she was a presidential candidate and
she's young democratic candidate yeah
i think she's a currently um active
military too right
yeah i think yeah she's dope but what
happens is
the young people and like most people
say they want bernie right
yeah but then maybe half those people
may not even half would actually go out
and vote for him
well that's what usually happens with
young people is they'll talk old people
with the ones actually
last year was dope i saw like every year
uh leading up to 2020. i've seen a lot
more young people going out and
there's definitely a lot more which is
dope and i think like we just need to
keep getting people to
like i think this year it's going to be
big too just we'll see
but it's it's there's definitely a lot
of people that online they probably like
oh my retweet
like me saying it you kind of get or i'm
like i'm lazy and like won't actually go
but at least i
me hopefully i convinced someone else to
go and do it you know where there's
actually people that they're not talking
about they don't tweet
it's kind of like that situation where
someone needs help in public but then
every person passing by thinks oh
someone will help him and then that
person never gets help
yeah the dispersion of responsibility
and then it's like if you actually have
you been to like a place to vote
yeah a lot of people i think the
democratic national committee needs to
clean the [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
i mean think about with the first uh
uh election with the with with how
hillary actually you know
corrupted you know she she worked with
the committee to [ __ ] snub out bernie
and then the second time they did it
again
and then they have this corporate puppet
which is biden he's a huge puppet dude
he's a [ __ ]
tool dude i'm like man right when we're
starting to see some change right when
we're starting to see like
actual you know everyday people in
politics that
are saying the [ __ ] that i want to hear
tulsi's against the military-industrial
complex and she is a military person
saying we need to stop this [ __ ]
right and um yang too he's pragmatic
he's coming out and i mean his campaign
sounds socialist but at the same time
it's a catch you go oh yeah i want a
thousand dollars a month
it gets the average person to start
having a conversation
but his main campaign was about hey you
guys are talking about bring jobs to
america but y'all are stupid because
there's gonna be no jobs all the robots
are gonna replace you
you need to start figuring out some [ __ ]
right now on how you can survive
and i love that because he's not out
here going like race issues or whatever
which are important but i would think
that paying the bills are much much more
important
than somebody called me a certain name
most of middle america
felt like trump's gonna get us like get
us those jobs and we're gonna get to
he took a lot of obama votes because
people who voted for obama
they thought that the change the hope
all those things that he campaigned on
was going to happen which was just
another eight more years of bush
policies
so what ended up happening was a lot of
those
angry you know middle class or used to
be middle class manufacturing jobs all
those guys said well [ __ ] that
i'm gonna go to a president that wants
to do something for me
and then hillary's campaign was all
about i stand with her
female empowerment not true i mean
female empowerment is great but does it
pay the bills for the people that are
struggling
that's the dnc for you though the dnc i
think they run
too much solely on the identity politics
yeah and
like yeah they're important problems but
at the end of the day
it's not gonna it's just the face yeah
it's not gonna put pay the bills it's
not gonna make us survive as a nation
and i think that's the thing is
sometimes when we're looking at it from
such
the the democratic party is a party of
of big cities
it's not the rural areas it's not you
know
struggling communities outside of the
major cities right so then some
we we have this like major city
perspective
where we forget that there's this whole
country out there
and some towns rely on just a factory
one factory or whatever and then i think
it [ __ ] sucks because then
you have all these people who are like
yeah man we need to change
things we need to treat each other nicer
and it's like that's great we're
campaigning on that
but there's a whole lot of people who
are just trying to survive
and there's no politicians out there
that are like saying
hey this is how we're gonna heal
america's economy
they're always talking about identity
politics
he said this this guy's an idiot it's
the stupidest [ __ ] thing first world
problems
which then leads people to believe like
okay well
nothing ever gets fixed there must be
someone in charge
making sure that nothing ever gets fixed
so it's like a whole
ass circuit and that's why i think if we
throw biden in there nothing's gonna
happen
yeah they're just gonna do lip service
it's gonna go right back
to corporatocracy corporatocracy yeah
hello guys thank you guys so much for
watching all of our videos and i know
it's been a million years
in the making but we finally got just
kidding news
merch yup so make sure you go down to
the store below
and you can run around yeah you can get
a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
so
you